さて
、私たちはライブだと思います。
リンクを共有します。
大丈夫です。甘い
です。
ちょっと、ええと、ライブストリームは
いくつかの質問に答えるかもしれませんので、ええと、私は
数分待つ
かもしれません。
始めた
ばかりです。最近あなたのチャンネルについて知りました。私は
それが大好きです
。あなたの日本語の
発音はとても面白いです。ありがとうございます。
最初の最初のストリームに感謝します。
私の眼鏡
は本当にチャットを読むことができませんええと
、
あなたがこれまで
日本語で間違って言った中で最も恥ずかしいことは何ですかええと、私は
覚えていませんが、私の
頭に浮かぶの
は、私が一度友達と一緒だったということです
私たちはこの2人の日本人の女の子と話していました
友達は多分行けるかもしれないと言ったのですが、いつか飲み物を飲み
に行けるかもしれないと言いたかったの
ですが、
誤って
酔っ払って言ったのではなく、私たちが
本当に変だと思ってすぐに逃げてしまったのはおかしかったです。
でもそれは良い例でした
ええと、高低アクセントの先生がストリーミングをしているのを見てみましょ
うええと、
それほど頻繁ではありませんが、
今日は少し余分な時間
があります。  2000年代半ばに、
あきらめて出て行きたいと思ったことは
ありませんか。
ここに住んでいるのと同じように、私はいつも
楽しんで
います。
他の人のほとんどが日本で良い砕氷船を知っていると言うのに比べて本当にホームシックになりすぎます
ええ
と天気がいいです
あなたは将来東京周辺での
会合を考えていますか 多分
ええと
コロナが落ち着い
たら 関西方言で
日本語を学ぶにはどうしたらいいか見てみ
ましょう関西に移動し
ます。1秒メッセージが届きました。
すみません、妻が
コーヒーを飲み終えたので
、すぐにコーヒーを飲みに行きます。 すぐに戻ってきますごめんなさいすぐに戻ってき
ますコーヒーを飲みたいです
[音楽]
ああ
はい
[音楽]
は
外国人
です大丈夫あなたは困るでしょう
[音楽]
私の
b
外国人だ
から
外国人の
男何 あなたは何をしているのですか